late morning on a sunny summers day it's
quite surreal so I've been drawn into
darkness into nighttime at the top the
TV transmitter for the North West of
England and other key communications man
this is the Battle of Winter Hill
they're using hoses beaters and even
leaf blowers but actually pull down the
air around the fire the Lancashire side
is relatively contained but it's this
perhaps two or three hundred meters of
land that is not yet burnt up here on
Winter Hill that is the effort now to
try to make sure that it stays that way
and that they preserve this gap and they
keep the ring around this communications
hub it was getting worse by the minute
you can see the visibility is really bad
yeah yeah it is demoralizing you just
feel like you're fighting a losing
battle but it's got to keep trying on
here they don't need the public up here
but on the other side of the hill some
just carried on two fires coming
together now yeah you still happy to
come for a war though well yeah within
minutes the fire fighters week-long
baffled
effectively they decided everyone's got
to get off
[Music]
how does that feel you've been working
so hard on this
[Music]
and that's that everyone has now got to
get down off the hill including us and
we're just gonna have to leave this to
carry on burning it was soon declared a
major incident the two fires have now
become one nobody wants to walk off this
job it's their fight that is now in the
balance
Tom Parmenter Sky News Greater
Manchester